president biden's policies blow up
prices panic buying hits the southeast
as the gas runs out
and liz cheney's firefight with gop is
everything the media could hope for
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressvpn
it's time to stand up to bigtech protect
your data at expressvpn.com
we'll get to all the news in just one
moment first you've heard it said there
are only two sure things in life death
and taxes well there is a third sure
thing that is you are paying too much
money if you are getting your cell
phone coverage from verizon a t or
t-mobile instead switch on over to pure
talk usa switching to pure talk will
save you money in fact
pure talk saves the average family for
over 800 a year here is the best part
you don't have to sacrifice coverage
because it's on the exact same network
as one of those big providers
friends switching is super easy you can
keep your phone keep your number or you
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids right now
you can get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data for just 30 bucks a month
and
if you go over on data they're not going
to charge you for it just one of the
many reasons they've been named the top
wireless provider by consumer affairs
from your cell phone so i'll pound 250
say ben shapiro you will save
50 off your very first month that is
pound two five zero say ben shapiro and
when you go to one of the big cell phone
coverage providers
they will just not really be very clear
about what it is that you are buying
they give you these kind of opaque
answers as to what it is you get not so
at pure talk usa you get unlimited talk
tech six gigs of data for 30 bucks a
month and again
if you go over on that data they're not
going to charge you for it so you got
nothing to lose from your cell phones
i'll pound 250 and say ben shapiro to
get started you'll save 50
off your first month and hundreds more
down the road alrighty so
the federal government is now admitting
that inflation has set in
according to cnbc.com inflation in april
accelerated at its fastest pace in more
than 12 years
as the us economic recovery kicked into
gear and energy prices jumped higher
the labor department reported on
wednesday the consumer price index which
measures
measures a basket of goods as well as
energy and housing costs rose 4.2
percent from a year earlier
a dow jones survey had expected a 3.6
percent increase this is actually even
higher
the month-to-month gain was 0.8 in
against the expected 0.2 percent
excluding volatile food and energy
prices core cpi increased 3
from the same period in 2020 and 0.9
percent on a monthly basis so all you
have to do to get to that
slightly less alarming number is exclude
the two biggest costs that people
generally take on
food and energy the respective estimates
we're now 2.3 percent and 0.3 percent
the increase in the annual headline cpi
rate was the fastest since september of
while the monthly gain in core inflation
was the largest since 1981.
okay so this is the largest core
inflation that we've had month over
month
in 40 years and we're supposed to be
like okay with this apparently
energy prices overall jumped 25 from a
year earlier including a 49.6
increase for gasoline and 37.3 percent
for fuel oil that came even though most
energy categories saw decline in april
prices at the pump
which fell 1.4 percent in april have
resumed their climb in may with the
national average eclipsing three bucks a
gallon
remember this was all before the
colonial pipeline
shutdown okay so that massive increase
in energy costs
was before the colonial pipeline
shutdown used car and truck prices which
are seen as a key inflation indicator
because
frankly the prices generally stay pretty
stable with used cars and trucks instead
they searched 21
including a 10 percent increase in april
alone
shelter another key cpi component was up
2.1 year-over-year and 0.4
for the month in addition to rising
prices one of the main reasons for the
big annual gain was because of base
effects meaning inflation was pretty low
in 2020 because of the shutdown of the
us economy but
if you look at the chart what you see is
this radical increase over the last
couple of months not a steady increase
couple of months
in the inflation rate and this is
accompanied by the fact that federal
taxes spending and the deficit all set
records
through the first seven months of fiscal
federal tax revenues have hit a record
2.1 trillion dollars for the period
federal spending claim to four trillion
dollars just for the last seven months
resulting in a federal deficit of nearly
two trillion dollars over the last seven
months alone while the historical
october through april tax revenues are
adjusted for inflation
into april 2021 the second highest tax
revenues of the october through april
period came in fiscal 2018.
that year the treasury collected 2.1
trillion dollars in total tax revenues
in the first seven months
when you actually adjust those numbers
the october through april spending
numbers into april 20 to 21 dollars
the second highest spending during that
period came in fiscal 2020. so we are
just blowing out the spending we are
blowing out the taxation
and we are blowing out the deficit
meanwhile joe biden has no idea what the
hell is going on
it was funny when the biden
administration came into office the
media
not only celebrated because trump was
out but they said competence is back
these people are so unbelievably
competent
no they're not no they're not okay the
great lie of american politics is that
american politics resembles house of
cards there's a bunch of very clever
people in washington dc
who are manipulating the system who have
plans these plans pan out
wrong okay all of american politics is
like veep or in the loop
all of american politics is a bunch of
morons running around a top speed
crashing into each other to the benny
hill music that's
all politics is okay just like you in
your own business
how many really smart people are there
in your business the answer is like
seven
okay how many really smart people are
there in american politics like seven
out of millions okay and they are never
at the top of the american government
the american government is filled with
dullards and not only dollars
incompetence and incompetence who have
been boosted
in their incompetence for literally
their entire lives i mean joe biden has
not spent a moment
outside of elected office except for
when he was in vp for like five minutes
since he was 30 years old okay which
means that he's been on the taxpayer
dole
he is significantly less useful as a
person than many people who are on
welfare for that period of time
he's on taxpayer dollars too and he's
been useless that entire time when he's
not reversing himself or pushing bad
policy
he just is running around and
competently flailing okay so that's what
he was doing yesterday we've got
inflation that is starting to kick in
it is purely due to the fact that he's
blowing money into the u.s economy at
record rates we did this last year
we did it thanks to a pandemic now we
don't have a pandemic anymore the
pandemic is coming to an end
everyone except for the cdc acknowledges
this and knows this
and yet he is still trying to usher in a
period in which he spent 10
trillion dollars he has proposed not
only the four trillion dollar budget
but three separate two trillion dollar
bills on top of that how do you think we
are going to pay for that
he says we're gonna do it through
increased taxation we're not gonna do it
through increased taxation
all of his tax measurements are taken
over the course of 15 years and all the
spending is done over the course of
eight years
that's not how any of this works if you
are going to measure tax revenues
against the spending you have to take
the same period of time that's like
saying well you know
i'm i'm really not blowing out the
deficit because in the next six months
i'm gonna spend a million dollars but
you know in the next five years i'm
probably gonna make a million dollars
yes but there's that intervening period
between six months and five years we're
going to continue spending money none of
that makes any sense
it's not going to be through tax money
it's going to be through financing via
the federal reserve
okay all that is happening right now is
that the united states is blowing out
the deficit and the federal reserve is
blowing credit into the system we have
maintained a zero percent
interest rate despite the fact that we
are now in a growth period
we are super heating the american
economy we are super heating the
american dollar and we are inflating
prices
that's all that is happening right now
and we are creating an artificial
scarcity of labor
we are paying people to stay home so joe
biden
this incompetent boob yesterday he was
asked about inflation and he just
ignored it
i mean i don't know whether he heard it
there's not much going on upstairs
anymore
for joe there never was all that much
going on upstairs for joe biden but even
joe biden of 2021 is not the same as joe
biden of 2015 for example
and again in 2015 joe biden was no great
shakes and
barack obama thought that joe biden was
a dullard what do you what are the rest
of us supposed to think here's joe biden
anyway thank you guys should americans
be worried about inflation sir
okay thank you bye thanks
god go see you later even some of the
moderate senate democrats are beginning
to look a scans
at the democratic program here but not
joe biden not members of his
administration
we'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that when you walk into your home
probably redid the floors recently maybe
you repainted but something still looks
a little dingy
let me note what that is that is your
window coverings and then think about
your window coverings right still got
the old blinds
you've still got the old curtains they
don't look very good instead you need
blinds.com blinds.com makes it simple to
shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping the experts
at blinds.com understand that window
treatments are one of the household
items
you just don't think about but they can
make a huge impact on the look and feel
of your home
you don't need to do a full renovation
by simply changing what's on your
windows you can change the way light
comes into your home
create a totally different feel i'm very
big on natural light in the home
and you need great shutters shades to
make sure
that that light is coming in the way
that it's supposed to come into your
house go to blinds.com just take a look
at all the options i've got faux wood
blinds cellular and roller shades even
outdoor shades
all sorts of great stuff if you're
nervous about trying them there is no
reason to be blinds.com has helped
millions of homeowners
through the process plus they guarantee
the perfect fit whether you do it
yourself or have the measure and install
everything
for you go right now see how much you
can save at blinds.com when you check
out online don't forget to tell them you
heard about blinds.com from this show
the ben shapiro show rules and
restrictions may apply
blinds.com and remember to let them know
you heard about them from the ben
shapiro show okay so
even democrats are now looking a scant
at joe biden's big spending plans
according to politico senate democrats
are signaling they are unlikely
to extend a 300 federal weekly
unemployment benefit past september
especially if the economy continues to
recover senate majority leader chuck
schumer said at a tuesday press
conference there was overwhelming
support among democrats to keep
providing the additional money to
existing unemployment insurance
but not every member of his caucus is on
board particularly after last week's
weaker than expected april jobs report
senator joe manchin democrat of west
virginia is already making it clear he
will not support extending the benefits
past september 6.
he said i'll never vote for another
extension as long as i know that with
the vaccines there's not an excuse for
no one to be vaccinated i understand
there's millions of
jobs in america we can't fill right now
we need people back to work
there's more and more people
understanding they are in trouble
manchin had previously expressed
hesitation over the benefit and a vote
earlier this year he backed only
extending the added money until mid july
but then he voted for the so-called
american rescue plan which was just
blowing money into the economy for no
reason
now manchin is far from alone in his
concerns senate republicans won't
support another extension
i would expect that kirsten cinema would
be not particularly warm
toward another unemployment extension
senator ron wyden democrat of oregon of
course
is a radical leftist and chair of the
senate finance committee he said there
had been report after report indicating
it wasn't accurate that the benefits
discouraged work
oh weird because um actually when you
pay people to stay home they stay home i
mean i know it's a giant shock to folks
but when you pay people to stay at home
they stay at home meanwhile
the there are other democrats who are a
little bit skeptical it's not just
mansion
several senate democrats said they were
taking a wait and see strategy on the
issues
adding they would need to assess the
economic situation this summer and
noting potential regional differences
right so that would include people like
angus king in maine
or john tester in montana he noticed
that this runs very much counter to the
new democratic agenda point of universal
basic income
and if you felt that paying people to
stay home didn't discourage work
then you would be on board for permanent
extension of increased unemployment
benefits you are not
because the reality is we don't have the
money for this and you are artificially
decreasing the supply curve and when you
do that
you're artificially increasing the price
of goods
and even democrats in the media are
starting to realize that
austerity may be on the table noah smith
who writes for bloomberg opinion and is
certainly no right winger
he is now pointing out that there are a
lot of people who are worrying about
overheating of the economy warren
buffett recently called the economy red
hot
said he's seeing higher prices some
wealth managers are starting to tell
clients inflation is on the way
some economists like larry summers and
muhammad al-aryan are giving the exact
same warning again all of this is what
happens when you artificially decrease
the labor supply and artificially
increase
the monetary supply and now the fed
could start reining this thing in but
they have no im they have no interest in
writing this thing and janet yellen has
made clear
that her priorities are not keeping
inflation low and keeping unemployment
low
her prio those were supposedly the
priorities of the federal reserve
now she's the head of the u.s treasury
she says equity is the priority so long
as there are certain groups in america
that are less employed than other groups
in america she's just going to keep
blowing money into the system
okay well it turns out that the easiest
way that you reach equality of outcome
is by depressing everyone
it is much harder to make everyone
succeed at the same level than to
depress everybody to the same level
and that is precisely what is happening
meanwhile this utterly incompetent
administration
has no answers with regard to the
colonial pipeline
debacle according to the washington post
a sudden fuel shortage worsened across
the eastern half of the united states on
wednesday
after a cyber attack crippled the major
pipeline as long lines sharp boards and
pumps
gone dry greeted unhappy drivers from
the alabama foothills to the chesapeake
bay
i know in florida there are a lot of gas
stations that have been running out of
gas people have been driving gas station
to gas station trying to
find gas people across the southeast and
now up into the northeast
have been waiting in fuel lines very
reminiscent of the 1970s
there's a ridiculous there's a
ridiculous video of a woman attempting
to
take plastic bags and fill them with
gasoline which prompted the
transportation department to tweet out
please don't fill plastic bags
with gasoline it's like come on man
there's america we fill whatever we want
with gasoline but
although government and industry
officials said the nation had plenty of
fuel and the pipeline was set to resume
operations in the evening
nervous drivers clogged gas stations and
created shortages in parts
or all of 11 states at least 12 000 gas
stations reported being completely empty
the squeeze pushed the price of gallon
past three bucks its highest in years
now the colonial pipeline hack isn't
biden's fall
right colonial pipeline's a private
company sure our cyber defenses need to
be better
but you can't really blame biden for
that what you can blame biden for is
that his
basic policy has been anti-gas and oil
since before he took office
he's been pressing forward with this
green new deal nonsense which
substitutes
significantly inferior forms of energy
in terms of efficiency
for things like gas and oil and
yesterday he had energy secretary
jennifer granholm
openly stating that you know this
shortage of oil might not be a bad thing
because maybe people will buy teslas
yeah it turns out not everybody can
afford a tesla it turns out that
electric cars
are very very expensive especially
decent ones
and meanwhile joe biden for some odd
reason again he's just not with us
joe biden is untethered from reality
yesterday he was asked about these these
gas lines
and joe biden started rambling
nonsensically about how we need to spend
more on education
the wires got crossed or something like
this this
person is he's the president of the
united states and we are told he's uber
competent
he's not even competent i mean i wonder
if he's legally competent
forget about like competent to be
president of the united states i wonder
if he is legally competent at this point
he has lost it he didn't have much to
begin he has lost here he is
what does education have to do with the
colonial pipeline problems
i think what this shows is that
i think we have to make a
greater investment in education
as it relates to being able to
train and graduate more people
proficient in cyber security that's your
takeaway
i mean i will give him credit he's able
to swivel everything to let's spend more
money
so somehow he's going to connect the
hack
on the grid on the on the cyber on the
uh on the
pipeline here he's going to connect that
in some odd way
with we're not spending enough money on
cyber
security education it's a take
it's a take that makes no sense but
that's the president of the united
states man meanwhile pete buda judge the
greatest of all transportation
secretaries a very important person
who is excellent at transportation
because the dude loves choo choo trains
he talks all the time
about how much choo-choo trains are they
make him happy he likes when they go
choo-choo particularly
he loves the chili tree he also loves
airports airports are great and romantic
this is what he said in his opening
speech that he is he's in love with
transportation
because he likes things that go they
have wheels and stuff they're cool
choo choo trains in airports for our
transportation secretary who couldn't
fill potholes in south bend
but is now the transportation secretary
for no reason anyone can discern
because he built ice town he's just that
he's he's
been wyatt from parks and recreation
this guy and they made him
transportation secretary it's unreal
of course we understand the concern in
the areas where people are encountering
temporary supply disruptions but
hoarding does not make things better
and under no circumstances should
gasoline ever be put into
anything but a vehicle directly or an
approved container
you can see even even buddha jets is
sort of embarrassed by the fact that he
has to say this sort of stuff
okay first of all he when he says
hoarding is not good for anybody well
it's kind of good for the person who has
the gas when nobody else has the gas i
mean to be fair
hoarding isn't bad for that person and
meanwhile what is the alternative that's
being proposed by the
biden administration they have so many
wonderful alternatives to oil and
natural gas like for example solar
panels
right solar panels have been proposed as
a solution to our energy crisis
here is john kerry
in front of congress yesterday being
forced to admit yeah we love solar
panels solar panels are great also
they're being made with weaker slave
labor in china that's unfortunate
zhanjiang province not only produces
some of the solar panels
that we believe are being in some cases
produced in forced labor
by uyghurs but also
there are significant amount of
rare earth mineral that's used in the
solar panels themselves
it is my understanding that the byte
administration is right now
in the process of assessing whether or
not that will be
the target of sanctions okay but um we
need the solar panels so you know
sure the solar panels we love are made
by forced labor in china but you know
you know man this administration they're
just a bleep show they really are like
from top to bottom the incompetence is
extraordinary so here's the thing about
the trump administration
the messaging was incompetent the policy
was not incompetent you know how you
could tell in a booming economy all the
way up
until kovid you had zero foreign policy
crises
during the entirety of the trump
administration like think of a serious
foreign policy crisis
during the trump administration there
really wasn't one in the first hundred
days you have massive inflation under
joe biden you have a middle east that is
blowing up
thanks specifically to joe biden's
policy you have unemployment
that is setting in in the middle of what
should be an easy natural economic
recovery
and you have tremendous vaccine
hesitancy because these morons can't
tranch out
their information about the vaccine
properly okay
the the amazing thing about all of this
which i'll get into
in just one second the most amazing
thing about all this truthfully
is that this administration their
policies they are completely dependent
completely dependent on the old cout
who can't speak three sentences i'll
explain in just one sec it really is i
mean he i've called him president house
plant before because he is just a barely
alive thing hiding the water stain
they are so dependent on joe biden it's
incredible it's incredible
i mean people are pretending that joe
biden that he's kind of an irrelevant
figure he's not a relevant figure he is
the most relevant figure in the sense
that were he to go away tomorrow were he
to retire were he to step down
god forbid something were to happen to
him the democratic party would be in
such significant and immediate trouble
everyone inside the democratic party
knows this we'll get to that in just one
second first
let us talk about the fact that you
don't want to be spending your time at
an auto parts store like now or ever why
would you want to wait in line you
finally get to the front of the line and
then
they search for the part that you need
and then they order it online and they
up charge you or you could just go
directly
to the source rockauto.com it's much
easier than walking into a store and
someone's manning quick answers
to specific questions like whether your
odyssey is in lx or an ex
instead just go to rockauto.com it's at
your desk it's in your pocket
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like airlines do why
would you spend up to twice as much
for the same parts like say for example
is off top my head i'm totally not
reading this you need a delphi fg 1456
fuel pump assembly for a 2005 to 2010
honda odyssey
just right off the top of my head like i
know it costs 354 bucks at a big chain
store that is the kind of thing you
could get
at rock auto for 217 bucks rockauto.com
is a family business they've been
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years
go check them out right now go to
rockauto.com see all the parts available
for your car
or truck write shapiro in there how did
you hear about us box so they know
that we sent you go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car truck and again let them
know
that we sent you by writing shapiro in
there how did you hear about us box okay
so
this administration its policy is so bad
and it's all dependent
on the continued aliveness of joe biden
the barely aliveness of joe biden that
is that that's it
okay so joe biden again he's it's
amazing they're
it's it's weekend to bernie's they are
just wheeling him around on a gurney
and he says a couple of things then they
wheel him off slowly it's the weirdest
it's the weirdest presidency i mean you
thought the trump presidency was weird
just on a raw level because
donald trump was a reality tv star who
tweeted like whatever random crap came
into his brain
he had twitter logoria i'm not sure that
this is not significantly weirder
because joe biden
every time he speaks it's like the door
to the crypt keeper open like
click and then they just wheel them so
weird man
here was joe biden yesterday openly
saying i'm not supposed to be answering
questions
no you are you're the president of the
united states you're supposed to be
answering questions
thank you what's your take by the end of
your meeting sir were you optimistic
coming out of it today
which one which one of the 12 i've had
[Music]
infrastructure sir and in particular you
guys are bad i'm not supposed to be
answering all these questions i'm
supposed to leave but i
can't resist your questions what you
guys are bad i'm not supposed to be at
you yeah you're very naughty you naughty
asking
journalists i'm supposed to i'm supposed
to leave
and well well come on
what is going on what's going on
he completely forgets where he is in the
middle of sentences yesterday
he was talking about meeting with the
house minority leader kevin mccarthy he
probably should know his name he's the
house minority leader
here is the president of the united
states completely forgetting kevin
mccarthy's name
i'm encouraged not just because of
a solid meeting with um
with uh the
republican leader in the house and with
with mitch or senator mcconnell who i've
known a long long time and worked with
he does this all the time you remember
he forgot the name of his own defense
secretary
he is not with us can you know why he's
important gang
because you know who's waiting in the
wings
[Laughter]
yes we all know kamala harris you know
that laugh
you know that mute that's the
undertaker's music kamala harris is
waiting in the wings
here is the problem americans do not
like kamala harris at all
joe biden is at least above 50 approval
ratings there's a brand new poll from
yougov here is what it finds
among all u.s adults she has a 41
favorable rating and a 48
unfavorable rating including a 57
percent unfavorable rating among
independents
they are completely dependent on this
old coupe remaining barely sentient
in order to ram through this garbage
agenda it's absolutely unbelievable
it's unbelievable okay meanwhile you can
see
how the media are swiveling away from
this so you have middle eastern flames
you have massive inflation you have an
economy that is in the doldrums even
though we should be
in the greatest period of economic
growth of our lifetimes i mean bar none
right we were expecting that gdp growth
this quarter was going to be just
astounding and instead we got job growth
that was
three quarters of a million jobs under
what it was supposed to be this month
all of that is happening they're pushing
for radical social policy that shifts
the nature of the deal between
individual americans and the federal
government they're invading religious
freedom rights they're invading the
the ability of corporations to operate
as they want to with regard to
with regard to free markets like this
this administration is a bleep show and
the consequences are obvious to everyone
and so they are deeply reliant on joe
biden so the media who are basically
they're not basically they just are the
pr wing of the democratic party that's
all they are the establishment media
understand there is no distinction
whatsoever between the dnc press office
and the actual press there's no
distinction they are the same the same
people occupy the same positions which
is why they move so smoothly from one to
the other you'll see people working for
the new york times and then suddenly
they just pop up
boom right there in the bible
administration you see it on cnn all the
time
it's not rare okay so they've decided
that they are going to misdirect away
from the chaos that has been engulfing
pretty much everywhere
and they're going to misdirect toward
this liz cheney story now
as i've been saying does anyone know who
the number three house
minority party leader was like five
years ago can you name the person
having trouble are you yeah because no
one cares who cares who the number three
is in the house minority party you're
not even talking about the house
majority party
talking about the house minority party
but liz cheney is getting all sorts of
press
because yesterday liz cheney was voted
out of her position as the number three
not the number two and not the number
one she was voted out as the number
three
in the house minority party specifically
because the republicans in the house
were getting frustrated with the fact
that liz cheney seemed to have a
peculiar predilection for the strange
new respect offered by the media
two months ago they voted on whether liz
cheney should stay she had exactly the
same position on january 6 then
that she does now she had exactly the
same position on
donald trump then than she does now she
had exactly the same position
on the veracity of the 2020 election
then as she does now but she withstood
the vote and
did so pretty easily with the support by
the way of kevin mccarthy the house
minority leader
then what happened she decided you know
it'd be a great idea i'm gonna go
into the media and pretty much every day
i'm just only going to talk
about how trump sucks and how
republicans who supported trump kind of
suck and how the 2020 election is legit
and january 6 was the worst thing that
ever happened
and all of this now when you're the
house minority leader
when you're the house number three i
should say you have a couple of jobs
okay and and those jobs are sometimes in
conflict
your job as a congress person is to vote
on issues liz cheney when she votes is
quite good
she voted like 94 of the time by the way
with donald trump when trump was
president
so she actually had a better record of
voting with trump than the new house
number three
uh who is the kind of aspiring house
uh elise stefanik from from new york
cheyney is much more conservative in
voting record than stephanie
but it's not just about your voting
record it's about can you raise money
for the party and
do you help orient the communications of
the party toward taking down the
opposing party or
are you directing all of your fire
internally are you spending all of your
time giving msnbc and cnn
and the washington post in the new york
times exactly what they want
now there is a difference between how
you message
and what you message okay i have said
many times on the show
that i agree with liz cheney's basic
basic take on january 6th
i agree with her basic take on how the
election of 2020 went i don't think it
was decided by voter fraud and
irregularity
i think that if there was rigging it was
by the media which lied consistently for
years
i think that trump's behavior between
the election and january 6th was pretty
egregious
i talked about it openly at the time i
talk about it openly now
and i agree with all those things but
let's be real about this the threat to
the country is not coming
from a president who has not been in
office for four months is banned from
twitter and facebook and has been
relegated to starting a blog
and then blasting out emails about how
much he hates liz cheney
these kind of bizarre emails okay that
guy is not the deep threat to the
country the threat to the country
is an authoritarian left that has taken
over every major institution in american
life
is on the move at the top of the
american government is creating
inflation
unemployment and chaos in the middle
east this
that is the threat why is liz cheney not
talking about that okay that is the
specific reason why she was ousted
again she had the same positions that
she does now two months ago and she
survived the vote
then she decided i'm gonna use the
intervening eight weeks to do nothing
but crap on republicans and republicans
predictably were like
you know what we don't need you in house
leadership that's not a thing that we
require
we can have any other republican who's a
better fundraiser than you and doesn't
spend all their days
trying to give joe scarbrough all sorts
of uh
of fever dreams like tr try not to do
that
if you're in house leadership okay so
cheney has been doing this thing
where she basically has made herself
hero of the republic
strange new respect recipients from the
left
and she has done so by suggesting that
the reason that she's being asked from
house leadership is not because for lack
of what we would call in hebrew seiko
or her lack of common sense the reason
she's being ousted from house leadership
is because specifically she took this
position
well it's a combo right she did take a
position that is fairly unpopular with
the republican base
but she could survive that she could
she absolutely could survive that
position if she did not make her top
priority
the the consistent weird take that the
great threat to the country is a
president who is no longer in office
and and is not widely influential
via his blog okay like there are greater
threats to the country right now you may
have
noticed okay but liz cheney has decided
that she kind of went into this thing
without an exit strategy
she decided she was going to start this
fight and she really didn't know how to
get out of it so the only way to get out
of it
is to keep on doubling down so here she
was yesterday
talking about how today's show vote
shows where the gop is
no what today's vote shows or
yesterday's vote showed is that the gop
does not wish to spend all waking
moments talking about a guy who's not
in office that if they ignore whatever
silly things trump is saying in his
emails and focusing on you know
the crises facing the country they'll
win back the house but you liz cheney
have spent every waking moment
apparently
dealing with trump i don't understand
why and no one else does either
but this is exactly what the media want
what the media wants they know the only
way the democrats are able to retain the
house in 2022
is by labeling the republicans too crazy
to be elected
right to say that the republicans there
the party of trump now that's a real
bank shot because trump ain't gonna have
been in office for a couple of years by
2022.
but that's really their only hope
because their own records sucks
the entire media is looking for this too
because they would much rather cover liz
cheney versus kevin mccarthy and the
republicans
then cover the fact that a doddering old
president who doesn't know what the hell
is going on is presiding
over a bizarrely timed collapse on
nearly every front
so here's liz cheney giving the media
exactly what they want
do you feel betrayed by today's vote i
do not i think that uh
it is an indication of where the
republican party is
and i think that the party is in a place
that we've got to bring it back
from and we've got to get back to a
position where uh we are a party that
can fight for conservative principles
that can fight for substance
we cannot be dragged backward uh by uh
the very dangerous lies of a former
president okay i have a question
who's dragging us backward who's talking
about this the most who decides that
it's important to answer every single
question the media asks you
about this sort of stuff and spend 90
percent of your time on it
there are two ways that you're dragged
backwards here okay one she's correct
you shouldn't go ahead you shouldn't go
around
suggesting that trump's for varications
are not for varications
they were you shouldn't go around
suggesting that biden in the president
binds the president
okay but there's another way you're
dragged backwards and that is
relitigating this thing over and over
and over as though it makes a damn bit
of difference
well that's what liz cheney's been
spending every day doing like kevin
mccarthy yesterday
he was uh he was specifically asked
about they said listen we're not
questioning who the president is we just
met with him five seconds ago
the conference will decide but i don't
think anybody is questioning the
legitimacy of the presidential election
i think that is all over with
we're sitting here with the president
today um
so from that point of view i don't think
that's a problem okay meanwhile
cheney is receiving exactly what you
would expect the stranger respects the
media
you think that liz cheney house number
three would be being interviewed by
savannah guthrie on national tv if this
weren't happening the media are all over
this because they don't want to cover
the actual news
okay this is not a big news story i'm
sorry an internal house battle
is not a big news story it's certainly
not a bigger news story than the fact
that the entire
house infrastructure for the democrats
last year refused to condemn melhanom of
her open anti-semitism so she just keeps
being an anti-semite
but the media didn't cover that either
in the same way this is blanket
wall-to-wall kind of stuff
because they need trump trump is a
distraction trump is the shiny object
trump is the misdirection and liz cheney
will substitute for trump
because she by dint of what she's
talking about makes trump the issue
so here is liz cheney with savannah
guthrie again
is this something that that a house gop
number three should be doing interviews
with msnbc's savannah guthrie
on the today show about how terrible the
other republicans are
do you think leader mccarthy has placed
his own ambitions
to be speaker of the house above
principle
i think that he is not leading with
principle right now
and i think that it is it's sad and i
think it's dangerous
and i think that we are at a moment
where
the republican party has to have leaders
that are focused on principle
i mean i'm i'm sorry well which which
principles are you talking about because
it turns out that there are several
different principles at play
one is focusing on the principle that we
don't lie about elections
agree then there is the principle of
stop the people in power from wrecking
the country are you doing that
really that's kind of a priority okay
i think it's a pretty good indicator
that you might be headed down the wrong
path here
when jen sackey from the white house is
praising you
it's disturbing to see any leader
regardless of party being attacked for
simply
speaking the truth and as the president
said last week
it's hard to understand uh but our
belief his belief
is that the american people will have to
make their own decisions
about whether the reaction by the people
they elected to represent them
should be embracing and elevating
conspiracies and attacks on our
democracy
or whether it should be standing up for
ideals that have historically been owned
by both democrats and republicans
representing
i'm sorry being lectured about election
veracity by the same democrats who
claimed for four years that trump was a
a russian cat spa suggest that al gore
was president and suggest that die bold
machines decided the 2004 election and
who keep elevating stacey abrams who
still refuses to acknowledge that she
was not legitimately elected the
governor of georgia
like spare me spare me just a little bit
by the way
how much do the media love this story
which is the the reason that liz cheney
ain't in leadership is because the media
loved this story so much how much does
the media love this story
according to the folks over at
newsbuster's curtis hook reporting
cnn spent nearly three times more
time on liz cheney in 12 hours than all
of the economic crisis that are hitting
the country right now
very very clear what exactly the agenda
here is okay in just a second
we'll bring you the latest from the
situation in israel the rockets continue
to fall
and rain down on israeli cities riots
are now plaguing israeli cities
as well and the american and
international left have decided the good
guys are hamas we'll get to this in one
second first
let us talk about the fact that if you
get carsick or you
tend to get a little nauseous from time
to time it's a really awful feeling i
mean feeling nauseated is
really really bad well relief band is
the number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband has been clinically proven to
quickly relieve and effectively prevent
nausea and vomiting associated with
motion sickness anxiety migraines
hangovers morning sickness chemotherapy
and so much more the product is 100
drug-free non-drowsing and provides
all-natural relief with zero side
effects for as long as needed
the technology was originally developed
over 20 years ago in hospitals to
relieve nausea from patients now through
a leaf band it's available to everyone
how it works relief and stimulates the
nerve in the wrist it travels to the
part of the brain that controls nausea
then it blocks the signal your brain is
sending to your stomach telling you that
you are sick
relief ban is the only over-the-counter
wearable device that has been used in
hospitals and oncology clinics
to treat nausea and vomiting if you know
somebody who deals with nausea relief
bad makes a great gift my wife tends to
get very car sick she has started
wearing relief band it is very effective
as the world's opening up don't let fear
of nausea keep you on the sidelines
right now relief man has an exclusive
offer
just for ben shapiro listeners if you go
to reliefband.com and use promo code
shapiro you will receive 20
off plus free shipping and no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee head
on over to reliefband.com
r-e-l-i-e-f-b-a-n-d.com use our promo
code shapiro for 20
off plus free shipping alrighty in just
a second we'll get to the latest
in the middle east first if americans
love anything it is their freedom
and it feels like there are some
powerful forces trying to take it from
you well that's because
they are small businesses are dying in
the name of public safety and kids are
being indoctrinated in schools
and we're being conditioned to fear
retribution from questioning the
accepted narrative we all
feel this right if you're working for a
company right now you're afraid your
bosses are gonna fire you
if you voted for trump if you are going
to school you're afraid that if you say
something that doesn't toe the leftist
line your professor is going to nail you
right you are worried about this because
we are living in an authoritarian moment
which is
coincidentally the name of my new book
the book is called the authoritarian
moment it goes through
institution by institution how the left
renormalized every institution
because you have to understand that in
order to fight back because that's
really what the book is about
how we renormalize make normal again
these institutions so
if you're interested in fighting back
against the authoritarian left which is
the movement that is on the march right
now
if you want to protect yourself your
loved ones from mob rule
and from the from the thought leaders
who've decided
to implement their authoritarian agenda
from above go check out my book today
the authoritarian moment it's available
for pre-order right now
at amazon barnes noble any other major
bookseller already soaring up the best
seller charts even a couple of months
in advance go check it out right now the
authoritarian moment you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile the rockets continue to fall
in israel hundreds more rockets fired at
tel aviv
and a lot hamas has also been launching
what they call
suicide drones according to the
jerusalem post hamas launched suicide
drones laden with explosives into israel
on thursday
at least one was believed to have
exploded in the air somewhere in central
israel the drone attack
came as over a hundred long range
rockets were fired in the direction of
tel aviv central israel and as far south
as a lot a lot of
the very southern tip of israel four
people were injured the rocket attack
came as the israeli defense forces
prepared for a possible ground invasion
of the gaza strip plans for a ground
offensive are scheduled to be presented
to the idf chief of staff lieutenant
general aviv kojavi for approval later
on thursday this of course makes perfect
sense because
the the gaza and hamas party has been
fired the terrorist group they've been
firing these missiles directly from
civilian areas israel
could theoretically bomb all these
places into submission they have
complete air superiority
they're not doing so specifically
because they attempted to avoid civilian
casualties which of course is why hamas
tends to hide all of its weaponry in
mosques
schools apartment buildings and
populated areas they're firing all of
their ordinance
directly from areas where they can use
human shields
meanwhile after a large barrage of
rockets toward central and southern
israel on thursday afternoon
abu ubaidah spokesman of hamas's
military wing the izadin al-kasam
brigades claimed hamas was launching
rockets toward ramon airport
after the barrage the lot regional
council located in southern negev
announced a rocket had fallen in the
regional council no injuries
were reported meanwhile the idf has been
destroying
government targets in the gaza strip
such as central banks and internal
security buildings
they've also killed some of the hamas
top leaders remember all of this was
initiated because mahmoud abbas canceled
an election in the palestinian authority
and then blamed the jews fomented
violence and then hamas got in on the
act and now israel is knocking out a
bunch of hamas leaders meanwhile world
leaders are calling mahmoud abbas
the guy who started this whole routine
it's pretty incredible the inside
outside game that is played by
palestinian terrorist groups continues
to amaze
the left's willingness to cover for
actual honest-to-god terrorist groups is
astonishing to me it really is an
amazing thing
hamas makes no bones about the fact that
they wish to wipe out every jew
okay this is not a conflict over land
this is not a conflict
over borders this is not a you have one
group that wishes to kill everyone of a
particular group and one group that
wishes to live
they're they're being very inconvenient
and that they are not willingly dying
there have been times in the past where
jews were quite soft in their own
defense it didn't end well for them
that's never going to happen again
that's why the state of israel exists
and people are angry that the state of
israel exists
and so you have to come up with all
sorts of bizarre justifications
for why israel is not right to defend
itself here
fortunately we have congress people
sitting congress people who are full on
in
on this sort of stuff so for example you
have alexander ocasio-cortez openly
defending hamas
right this genius so joe biden said that
israel has a right to defend itself
which by the way isn't it kind of
amazing that you have to actually say
that
israel which is a sovereign country has
the right to defend itself
what would the converse be it doesn't
have the right to defend itself of
course it has the right to defend itself
you know what happened if there were a
terrorist group or
say the government of mexico which is
actually what is going on hamas is the
government of the gaza strip
what if the government of mexico were
firing hundreds of rockets into san
diego
do you know how long that government
would last zero days we would be
planting the american flag in mexico
city immediately
okay this notion that israel is supposed
to sit around and bear this sort of
stuff is insane so biden says
israel has a right to defend itself
which is like the mildest form of okay
israel can kill a few hamas leaders
alexander ocasio-cortez then tweets out
blanket statements like these blanket
statements
what state doesn't have the right to
defend itself blanket statements like
these with little context or
acknowledgement of what precipitated the
cycle of violence
namely the expulsions of palestinians
and attacks on al-aqsa dehumanize
palestinians and imply the u.s will look
the other way at human rights violations
it's wrong so it's wrong for her
for the jewish state to defend itself
he's saying that israel doesn't have a
right to defend itself from ongoing
consistent rocket attacks
directed at civilians okay that's
there's a point where being anti-israel
shifts over into being anti-semitic okay
and at the point where you're saying
that the jewish state doesn't have the
same rights as any other state on planet
earth
you have reached this point okay
alexander ocasio-cortez tweeted out by
only stepping in to name hamas actions
which are condemnable when refusing to
acknowledge the rights of palestinians
biden reinforces the false idea that
palestinians instigated the cycle of
violence
of course they instigated this cycle of
violence are you insane
who's firing the rockets who started the
riots at al-aqsa
okay that is a lie to say that the
israelis started the riots in al-aqsa it
is not
true it is an overt lie she says this is
not neutral language it takes a side the
side of occupation
she's an ignoramus and she's a fool okay
and that is perfectly clear
but so but you know i will attribute
to i'll attribute ignorance to her i
will attribute malice to rasheeda to
lead so she talib is just a malicious
pro-terror liar so here's rashida talib
at a rally yesterday
promoting the the leftist idea the
international leftist idea
that the subjugated of the world are all
in solidarity
with one another and that the true story
of humanity is
white people all over and she she counts
jews with whites white people
all over who are subjugating brown
people all over this is something
that jamal bowman who's standing right
next to rashida to leave when she says
this
also is putting out there it's the
reason why black lives matter hasn't
has in its manifesto in its program and
the israeli occupation
and because there's a lie that is out
there going all the way back to franz
fanon that basically anybody
who has a european way of life is an
oppressor and anybody else
is not an oppressor they are victimized
and so the oppressed of the world have
to rise up in anti-colonialist fashion
right that's what this language is
so here's rashida talib suggesting that
what the
what the israelis are quote-unquote
doing to the palestinians is what the
police
do to black and brown people i assume
that's what she means by they because if
she doesn't mean the police
by they if she doesn't mean two separate
terms by they as you will see then she's
just talking about the jews
and that's just pure anti-semitism so
here's rashida talib suggesting somehow
a connection
between police treatment of black and
brown people in the united states which
again she lies about so israeli
treatment
of palestinians so there are a few
things that are wrong with this one
the police in the united states are not
systemically racist put that aside
number two the israelis are not white
okay this this this bizarre notion that
the israelis are white ignores the fact
that like half of israelis more than
half of israelis by percentage
are from arabic countries the jews who
have been killed in israel
there's some from yemen there's some
from morocco there
there are plenty of jews who are not
white okay and jews technically speaking
uh we're not white until like the last
five minutes when they became prominent
in american politics until then they
were considered an out group
okay but here's rashida talib pushing
this vile nonsense this vile racially
polarizing nonsense
and by the way pro hamas nonsense
because she has narrow words to say
about hamas firing
rockets indiscriminately into civilian
population centers and using human
shields in order to protect themselves
our freedom is interconnected with black
brown indigenous
what they are doing to the palestinian
people
is what they continue to do to our black
brothers and sisters here
to their local community here
so i want you to know this if you are
marching for freedom of fullest you
please
know that you must be watching for
everybody's freedom it is all
interconnected
it's all interconnected you see this is
how you grow this movement but by the
way it is
the truth for the left you wonder you
wonder about the red what the
people have termed the red green
alliance meaning the sort of communist
red red islamist alliance the answer is
they're
aimed at tearing down american
institutions tearing down western
institutions israel is seen as an
extension of that
they don't hate america because they
hate israel they hate israel because
they hate america
i mean this is the the basic notion that
rashida talib
wants is connecting the institutions of
the united states with what's going on
in israel in order to conflate all of
that
you have to acknowledge that what she's
really attempting to do is condemn all
of the systems of the west
because there is some supposed
underclass that is being repressed
by these systems and so she'll make
excuses for any level of violence in the
same way that
members of the radical democratic party
make excuses for people burning down
cities and murdering people
in the united states they make excuses
for hamas firing rockets
indiscriminately into civilian areas
now again this is all anti-factual
sumiya santosh is a 32 year old
indian woman who in order to care for
her nine-year-old boy found work in
ashkelon caring for an eight-year-old
woman
and uh she was blown up by hamas like
yesterday
nineteen-year-old yohuda guetta from
libya was shot and killed earlier this
week
by a palestinian-american named muntasir
shalabi who was motivated according to
his neighbors by equal parts jew hatred
and heavy gambling deaths
that according to tablet mag the the
basic
attempt to conflate american racial
politics with the middle east
is not only intellectually dishonest but
has terrible motivations okay and this
is by the way why you are seeing jews
getting beat up
in different places in the united states
yesterday in florida there was a truck
that was driving around
jewish rallies that saying hitler was
right and the conflation between
anti-zionism and zionism and
anti-semitism
not everybody who doesn't like israel is
an anti-semite but every anti-semite is
anti-israel
okay so it's it's it's pretty it's
pretty incredible to see these
narratives trotted out that perhaps the
dumbest narrative of course
is the narrative trotted out by trevor
noah so yesterday trevor noah literally
said that israel should stop defending
itself because they're too good at
defending themselves
just personally i cannot watch that
footage and hear those numbers
and see a fair fight like set aside
motives and intentions
and just look at technology technology
alone
israel has one of the most powerful
militaries
in the world and i know that people are
going to hate me for this
but i just want to ask an honest
question here
if you are in a fight where the other
person
cannot beat you how hard should you
retaliate
when they try to hurt you um as hard as
you need to to make them stop hurting
you also by hurt you i think that he is
making a
pretty significant category error here
there's a difference between
a child trying to physically harm me and
a terrorist group firing rockets at
people and murdering them
the answer is as much as you need to do
to stop hamas capacity
to commit terror attacks but i guess i
shouldn't be surprised because the
entire american left has also decided
that if a black girl swings a knife at
another black girl the cop shouldn't
shoot her because of power imbalance or
some such nonsense
none of this is shocking it's just
morally blind and moral blindness is the
name of the game when it comes to the
american and international left alrighty
we'll be back here today with an
additional hour of content coming up
soon
the matt wall show airs 1 30 pm eastern
be sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowsky
editing is by adam's science audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture
faith current events all the
fundamentals if they matter to you come
check out the show